du pain du yaourt et de l'eau c'est leur
pack ont pu préparer les enfants qui
sont venus cet après midi à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet on a fait de la
soupe pour les poules et les poches
et puis pour pourrait pour les vaincus
du par l'agglo il ya des activités
calmes un peu un peu ludique pédagogie
puis ça change chaque année là il y
avait un atelier cuisine c'est un peu
plus qu'une ferme
beaucoup d'activités ont été faites pour
les enfants comme une animation ils
apprennent à cuisiner leur goûter ou des
ateliers de soins aux animaux pour les
sensibiliser au monde de l'agriculture
c'est l'occasion pour eux de ba de voir
un petit peu la nature les animaux
comment prend soin d'eux comment les
nourrir
voilà les voir ailleurs en vrai plutôt
que dans un livre où ils connaissent les
noms mais de les voir en vrai c'est une
autre expérience
l'objectif d'alimentaire divine est de
présenter aux visiteurs des circuits
courts et mettre en avant les
producteurs et les activités de la ferme
la chance qu'on a c'est de pouvoir
rencontrer directement directement le
producteur de pouvoir savoir exactement
ce qu'on va mettre dans son assiette
on se rend compte que finalement le
produit n'est n'est pas forcément
beaucoup plus cher parce qu'il y avait
du coup moins d'intermédiaires et du
coup le consommateur achète directement
et on sait que l'argent va dans la poche
directement du
du producteur et justement il y avait de
nombreux producteurs des yvelines comme
la biscuiterie de la vallée de chevreuse
l'idée c'est surtout d'être proche des
consommateurs c'est à dire que pour moi
c'est important de venir à leur
rencontre de les écouter
j'ai moi j'ai pas de catalogue de
présentation de produits je ne marche
qu'à dégustation et il y avait de tout
sur les étals produits laitiers terrine
chocolat ou encore de la bière
prochain rendez-vous à la bergerie
nationale le 21 octobre avec une
nocturne une soirée lampions frissons et
dégustation